all right guys
bang bang i've got a special special
treat for you today
uh sean thanks for doing this man what's
up
how are you i'm doing well man i'm
thriving so you know
people always say you know how are you
doing and you say good or whatever so i
had this personal trainer i started
working with
and whenever he comes over he's like
how's it going i'm like i'm doing good
i'm doing great
but no matter what i say he one-ups it
so he'll be like i'm fantastic i'm
tremendous i'm thriving so like
whatever i say he has like a better word
and so now i'm like it's this little
game i play with other people
who are unsuspecting little you know
civilians because they'll just be like
you know
how's it going i'll be like today is one
of the top three days of the week
another like what
but i i like it it breaks up the you
know normal small talk
yeah look and uh people love to be
around people who are just enjoying life
so let's uh let's get into it um let's
just start with your background you've
done all kinds of cool stuff and have an
absolute wild story as an entrepreneur
but
where did you grow up and kind of how
did you get into entrepreneurship all
right
um i grew up all over the place i lived
in maybe nine different countries in my
life
i you know finished high school in china
i've started it in texas
i lived in australia then i moved to
silicon valley because i was like that's
that's the hollywood for startups let's
go there
um my story is pretty cool you know it's
pretty i don't know it's not like
some rags to rich's story but it is
interesting you know i thought i went to
duke university i thought i was gonna be
a doctor
um i finished all my pre-med
requirements and took the mcats was
ready to go to med school
and i had one class credit left and i
was like all right what do i want to do
so i said i talked to my friends i said
you know isn't it weird we've never
taken a class together and let's take
the easiest most
you know biggest blow-off class that
there is on campus and so we went
there's this
website called ratemyprofessor.com where
it says like ratings
and um and so i go on there i try to
find the biggest blow-off class offered
on campus
what's the easiest thing i can do and i
see this class called
getting rich and it's a five out of five
on ease it's a five out of five on like
teacher help and then there's a chili
pepper um next to her name
and the chili pepper means like the
teacher's hot so i was like okay this is
a winner
um so will you enroll and this class so
basically you know it's called getting
rich but basically a personal finance
class
the teacher herself had graduated 10
years earlier um
and she went and got rich doing stuff
you know she was she had a degree in
mandarin all her friends were going to
banking
law school and they were like good luck
with that mandarin degree
you know what are you gonna do with that
and this is you know 20 years ago
and so she was like i bet i can get a
job in china so she goes to china
she realizes chinese companies want to
do business with the west she becomes
the face of
those interactions and she makes a
killing she invests that money into the
stock market in 1999
she's like the internet seems cool she
rides the run-up of the dot-com
boom and just happens to luckily pull
out before the bust because she's like
oh i want to buy a house actually i'll
get into real estate
and then she rides a real estate boom
for another five years and so by 30
she's retired
she's rich she married the guy of her
dreams and she's like what i want to do
i want to go back to school and i want
to teach
what i wish i had learned the stuff that
actually helped me you know make it
they should teach this stuff in school
so i end up taking this class of hers
and it's basically
uh one day would be a personal finance
class like what the hell's a mortgage
and like
what compound you know interest does to
you over time and then on the other
side it would just be stories of
entrepreneurs and i as i was listening
to these which is you know if you're
listening to a podcast you probably like
stories of entrepreneurs as well
i was inspired i was like this guy has
lives a sweet life or this girl lives a
sweet life
they are clearly not that smart like
they're not that much smarter than me
and what they're telling me is look when
i started i didn't know jack [ __ ]
um and so if they didn't know it when
they started
um they didn't know anything when they
started i also don't have to know
anything when i'm started
and also they're telling me look
everybody's resume looks like anyway so
if you do want to go get a traditional
job later
it's better to have a story that stands
out and so uh that's a long way of
saying i had decided to skip med school
and i took the first dumbest idea i had
and started a business which was
um i started a cloud kitchen before
cloud kitchens were a thing i didn't
think it was i was just doing it because
i didn't have money to get a restaurant
so we created the chipotle of sushi and
i partnered with this food network chef
and i
tried to create this cloud kitchen for
sushi that was delivery-only restaurant
um and that took me down this adventure
i did that
i did a biotech thing with this
billionaire guy in australia
so i um i come to silicon valley because
i'm like look this is where the action
is
and um i meet this guy michael birch and
michael burch has made it
big he sold a company called bebo to aol
for 850 million dollars
he's had all other wins too that were
you know tens of he's built probably
four different products to tens of
millions of users
and so anyways this guy made it and he
decided he's gonna open up his own idea
lab
so it's his own little you know he built
the most like you know
pimped out penthouse office in san
francisco i still think it is the best
office in san francisco
uh he hired up 20 badass engineers and
he's like let's build it we own
everything no
no external investors will sell fund the
whole whole thing and let's try to find
another home run
and so i was like hey this sounds
awesome um my whole mindset moving to
silicon valley was look i've done a
couple startups myself
but i want to learn from somebody who's
done it before now
and um and so i you know this guy had
this guy done it before and i said
how do i pack for you know 20 years of
learning into the next four years of
work
um and so that was my mindset and you
know how do i pack 20 years of learning
into four years of work
i thought this idea lab will be great
because i'm going to get so many
different reps
on a whole bunch of different projects
and not as an investor but like as the
person building them um
building them with a team and so anyways
i did that with him for about five years
we had a whole bunch of flops
we had a couple things that actually
took off and you know got to like number
one on the charts you know but didn't
quite
have the longevity that we wanted um and
then the last thing was sort of the
i guess most successful one out of it um
which was a company
we actually bought the company bebo back
so after he sold it to aol aol does
nothing with it
he comes to me one day and says look
it's bibo's going to just be off
you know offshed and go into bankruptcy
we have the chance to buy it back
uh if you want to do something with it
so we buy it back for a million bucks
we um reinvent it as something new as a
esports platform
and uh ended up selling that last year
to twitch
and so uh exited to twitch and since
then have been uh
at twitch kind of um enjoying that
experience earning out my my deal
and um and getting to know something new
and so
uh that's what i do is i you know i'm an
entrepreneur built a bunch of stuff that
didn't work
i got a couple wins under my belt so
sold the last one to twitch
uh also hosts a podcast as well um that
i think you're gonna be on soon
called my first million uh where we just
brainstorm business ideas me and sam
it started off as an interview show but
we quickly realized what people liked
more was
when we would shoot the [ __ ] and just
brainstorm half-baked business ideas
that you could use to you know make a
million bucks
uh we don't have the time to do it but
so we just give away the ideas for free
because we already have our hands full
with our own projects and so
um yeah that that thing took off as well
and it's doing pretty well
so one thing that's really interesting
is the idea lab concept uh is not new
but um the way that it was funded and
kind of all of the different iterations
what were some of the biggest lessons
you learned
going through you know all of the uh
kind of start and stop and
failures and successes uh in that
concept
so i learned a lot about the individual
ideas and how to make an idea successful
or when to kill an idea which is really
hard
to actually learn as an entrepreneur you
can only learn that the hard way
but on the ideal lab front i learned
that idea labs suck
like don't do an idea lab it's a super
sexy tempting thing to do like every
successful entrepreneur like
you know kevin rose after he sells his
company he starts his own studio
um garrett camp after you know uber and
stumbleupon starts his own studio expa
um mark pincus after zynga like this is
the thing to do
uh you know because it makes sense you
still want to create new stuff like
you're not going to stop wanting to do
have new ideas you can't turn that
switch off in your brain if you're wired
that way
but now you got money and now you feel
like you kind of know what the hell
you're doing
and so you're like cool i'll bet on
myself we'll pick up a bunch of
different ideas because
again focus is really hard to do what's
not hard is being add and starting a
bunch of different projects
and so it's this tempting really fun
thing to do but ultimately i think
quite a bad idea if success is your
metric if you're trying to enjoy
yourself
it's great if you're trying to be
successful i wouldn't do an idea lab
and i advised a whole bunch of other
people who were trying to do their idea
labs
because they would say hey you know you
seem pretty smart and you've done this
for years like
i want to do mine and you know these are
some of the successful wealthiest people
in the world that are trying to do this
and they're failing too and so i think
that the challenge is
you get all these good things with a
startup studio you get a bunch of
at-bats that's good
you have um the ability to carry over
learning so when one project fails you
don't have to go get a job you just
start the next project that's also
really good um
what you lose though is the critical
thing that makes startups work
which is relentless focus and uh
back against the wall i have to make
this work i told my whole family i told
the whole world i'm doing this
i gotta find a way and with ideal lab
it's sort of like
you're doing this project it's exciting
at the beginning it kind of starts
you know you build a prototype oh that
feels like progress you get a few users
that feels like progress
and then you hit some wall or some
plateau where it just doesn't take off
right away
and um and what ends up happening is as
an entrepreneur normally you just power
through that wall
as an idea lab you're like oh you know
[ __ ] that project i'm gonna go do
something
how about that other idea we have that's
kind of still in that sexy fun early
stage
and so you end up giving up a little too
soon on all these projects or just being
distracted and not being like relentless
about it
talk to me about when you guys sold bebo
to twitch um
obviously it didn't sell for a million
bucks so there was some sort of
appreciation in
the value you guys created and then the
transition from kind of that
entrepreneurial
mindset and going to work every day
trying to build stuff from scratch to
now be an executive at
you know a pretty impressive company
yeah well selling it was interesting and
i'll share this story because
there's two types of sales there's type
one which is your instagram
like you built the thing it's taking off
twitter wants to buy you zuck is trying
to buy you like you know
everybody wants you investors banging
down your door they're saying no stay
independent
and you decide to sell um in that case
you've been
you you are on to something you're
winning you have a lot of momentum and
you're a threat to the industry that's
why you get
bought um then there's everybody else
and i have this like you know speech i
gave entrepreneurs privately which is
like you are not instagram because if
you're talking to me you're not
instagram
um meaning like if you're trying to
figure out how do i sell this thing
um you're in the you're in the camp of b
you're selling you're not getting bought
and so what i always joke is that i sold
a failing company now in truth we
weren't failing we actually had like you
know decent momentum but like
we weren't a breakout superstar company
that just everybody wanted to buy
i'm [ __ ] manufactured that sale and
you know it was because i realized look
if if we keep going down this path i
think winning looks like kind of a
middle of the road medium-sized company
that's not what my investors signed up
for that's not what i signed up for it's
going to be just as hard as
building a big company but we're going
to end up at a medium-sized company in
the success case so i was like look
um let's sell this baby
so i was like look let's let's sell this
baby and so i
went out and i pitched and i figured out
how do you sell a company and i have
this like whole deal framework of a
whole
process of like how to sell you know a
not instagram company
and we ended up getting a couple offers
and decided to go with twitch
um which was awesome like you know we we
sold it for eight figures like i can't
say
the exact thing because you know i don't
want jeff to get mad at uncle jeff to
come down and bring the wrath of bezos
on me but
um actually you know some stuff got
leaked so that that that wasn't my fault
but
um but basically we sold it for a good
outcome you know personally
life-changing money
um and you know now i got a new
experience which was go to twitch and
now
boom i'm at a 2000 person company you're
the market leader it's like the exact
opposite of a startup
like startup you're small and you're
nobody nobody knows you and now you're
at twitch and it's like the exact
opposite and i got to you know see what
that's like for the past year
um being at an executive company and
it's very very different
give me the 60 second overview of how
you solve company
how you sell a company um you figure out
first
everyone wastes their time thinking
about why they're so great and you need
to figure out
uh what store you fit into for the
acquirer
so what i did was i
taught i went to i thought about each
acquirer i talked to people on the
inside to figure out
hey what are the big uh problems you
guys have to solve this year
like what are the urgent problems you
have what are the either opportunities
you
you need to be chasing or like headaches
that like the ceo is worried about
and then i just ask myself how can i
pitch my company as a solution to that
problem
it's very much like building a product
but like most entrepreneurs don't go
about it that way they just start to
focus on themselves
here's what we do here's what industry
we're in here's how much traction we
have or don't have
and that's why they get stuck because
that's not an easy to understand thing
for an acquirer
so i went out and i mapped out 40
acquirers i
figured out what's what's the angle if
i'm them what what's
problem does buying bbo solve for me and
then i rank them on like
strongest fit to like weakest fit and i
started with the weakest fit and went
pitch practice that pitch and got good
at actually like answering their
questions and figuring out what
data they need and how to organize it
because i got some great advice along
the way
which was um you need to turn your
company into a giant buy button
like a one-click purchase from amazon so
like get your docs together get your
data room together uh clean up your cap
table clean up any messiness you have
um figure out you know your your three
sentence story that they're gonna go
pitch in their boardroom when they have
to go get board approval for this
and uh like work backwards from that and
the last thing is get uh what i call
your deal doulas so like i just had a
kid this year
i just learned about the you know the
process of having a baby
and um you know a doula is some you know
somebody who really helps and assists
you birth that baby
and you need the same thing with a deal
you need a deal doula to help you
you know a keep your head straight
because it's really like it can be very
stressful for people
be like negotiate figure out how
negotiations need to work
um and three like you know they they
open doors and they can kind of back
channel for you
in a way that really helps you and so um
when the ceo or the kind of whoever is
your champion at the company who's going
to buy you
they need to hear from multiple sources
and they need to sort of get reaffirmed
because
you don't want them to get fired for
acquiring your company so they need to
have high certainty that this is a good
deal
which is done in two ways they
understand it
other people tell them this is a good
deal and they see that other companies
want to buy you so you got to get
multiple offers
um and so that was my trick was get
multiple offers um
pitch myself as somebody that they you
know put myself in their terms how i
solve their problem this year
and um and get yeah just have have
people back channeling for you
you've got a number of uh what some
would consider um
irrational or counter intuitive ideas
i want to go through those and you just
kind of spitball at me why you believe
these things
uh the first is real estate is full of
rich dumb people what is that
it's not that it's full it is full of it
uh i got in trouble for this but i
believe it to be true
um real estate has the highest
percentage of dumb rich people
and people took that as an insult i
didn't mean it as an insult i meant it
as a compliment it means
hey you can get rich in this area
without having to be a genius like
dude i was trying to create the next
twitter next youtube that's hard to
catch lightning in a bottle
if i had just gone and done multi-family
real estate that does not take the same
level of luck and genius that uh other
things take
so that's why i say that and you know
peop real estate people get all pissed
when i say that but
uh a it's true and b it's not an insult
uh it's a way to say look if financial
gain is your number one thing to do
and you're not you don't have the ego of
trying or you know the
creative juices aren't just flowing out
of you um real estate's a great way to
go dumb rich people everywhere it's
awesome
hey who cares if you're dumb or smart if
you're rich right so
exactly uh project selection is more
important than
hard work i actually agree with this but
explain what you mean by that
yeah so hard work is this like thing
everybody crafts and crafts onto and i
had trouble with this because i'm not
that hard of a worker i'm actually quite
lazy
um and i thought for a while i believed
what society tells you which is that you
have to work really hard to be
successful
um sure it helps but like hey i got
successful and i still didn't work that
hard and like
so i definitely proved that this sort of
counter narrative there's plenty of
people that are like this
a far more important factor to success
is project selection most people choose
the wrong project so here's kind of how
i think about this i used to play poker
a lot
and in poker um i found that i would
crush it at certain games like if i
played at certain soft tables
like i lived in australia and it's just
dumb tourists playing poker or online
i'd go to the low stakes you know the
one two dollar
limit tables and i could just crush it
but then i would get my ego you know i'd
want to go heads up
for you know high limits and i'd you
know be sitting there with 50 grand at a
table trying to beat this guy because
he's good
and like what a dumb thing to do if my
objective is to make money
um that's a really dumb way to make
money i'm going where i don't have an
edge
and so i learned in poker they always
say table selection
is you know one of the critical factors
it's more important than being you know
sort of this genius bluffer
um and so in the same same vein for
startups or projects you're doing
you want to work on the projects where
you are where success is in your favor
not against you
and too many people try really hard
things and then try to
hard work their way out of it and that's
a terrible idea i want to go
to a waterfall and just get wet i don't
want to go in the desert and find
water like uh and i learned that the
hard way because i did a bunch of
projects that were like going in the
desert trying to find water
and then i have now experienced the
opposite and i i will
tell everybody this because i think
it'll save you a lot of pain uh
project selection not hard work so i
agree with everything you said
with one caveat which is if people could
select the right project
and then work hard it's like it's like
rocket fuel right
turbo it's a turbo for sure and like um
but what i'll say is
it's not an absolute requirement for
success but of course if you're both in
the same if
two people go into the same project and
then one works way harder than the other
they're gonna get better results
and um and so yeah it's for sure
additive
but it is misprioritized people people
say it because it sounds really good to
say it sounds like it like for example
i'm always wary of things that sound
good when you say them
i'm like is that really true so like for
example you
it's unpopular to say um intelligence
really matters
because it sounds like something that's
kind of outside of your control it
sounds kind of elitist
or saying like resources really matter
or like whatever your background really
matters
and these may or may not be true but
like they don't sound good when you say
them you don't you don't get
props in the you know on twitter uh you
don't get retweets for for saying this
stuff
but if you say hard work really matters
everybody likes to agree with that you
sound good it sounds like every it
sounds very fair
everybody's got a fair shot and the
harder you work the better results you
get
um in my experience that's not really
true hard work it helps
uh it is additive but it is by no means
the like
you know the thing that correlates best
to success
um much but there are many other facts
four or five other factors i would put
over
hard work number one i would say is
choosing the right project um
so so that's kind of like my my little
my cheat code i would always use is
anytime you see some something that is
just universally you'll get a pat on the
back for saying
you should really question if it's true
or if people say it because it signals
uh you know a good thing for them lots
of people saying things they think they
should be saying
right it's the uh it's the seeking of
consensus instead of truth
exactly uh yeah um people shouldn't join
early stage startups
yeah well the caveat here is you
shouldn't join it from it's a dumb
decision from a financial perspective
um uh i love early stage startups i you
know i've
turned down a lot more money to do early
stage startups i think
you should if you're really optimizing
for like let's say financial gain
um and that's not the main thing to
optimize for but if you are optimized
financial gain you should either start
your own company and own the equity
because the founder
the founder will get like you know 100
or 50 of the company when they start it
and then the first two employees who are
gonna be just work just as hard
take just as much risk uh pretty much
they will be
you know three percent or less uh you
know by the fifth employee you're
getting
point two five point three point point
four percent of the company which is
ridiculous
uh but that's the norm and so joining at
an early stage you do
you work really hard you just don't get
the same upside so i like to say if
you're thinking about money
which again you don't have to think
about but if you are own
own the company on the equity yourself
or go work at fang dude there's people
you know who work at fan companies that
are you can go out of college and be
making 300k a year if you're an engineer
i know people are making a million
dollars a year and they live a very very
relaxed lifestyle
taking none of the risk and headache
that uh an entrepreneur makes or
or a early stage startup uh person does
now
if you're trying to learn which is how
kind of how i thought about it when i
was young in my career i was like look
i'll earn later i'm going to learn now
i'm going to optimize for learning
working at early stage startup is great
yeah i completely agree with both of
those things um
the difference between acting like a
lion versus a cow and this might be my
favorite thing
uh that you've said i stole this one so
this i can't i can't take full credit
for but
hey i i steal 90 of my ideas i just you
know my job is to
find good ideas and share them uh not
claim to be the owner so naval actually
is the one who said this
um but it lined up with what i've
experienced which is
most people work uh monday through
friday and they work roughly like a nine
to five schedule
and i always when i was trying to work
that way it never felt right you know
like
i had always done my best work in like
extreme bursts where
once i had clarity on something or
motivation to do something like don't
talk to me for like 16 hours i'm gonna
just work on this thing like crazy
and then like i'll go two days i won't
do anything and you know my mom thinks
like
what are you doing like you should go to
work and um for creative
people and ambitious people uh work
you're not like a factory worker
you don't just go in monday through
friday like a robot and work for eight
hours straight and get the same output
per
hour uh it's definitely not that way not
all days are created equal not all hours
not all weeks are created equal
so if you recognize that you should say
well then how should i work
and um i think you should work like a
line so the way a line works this is
kind of the framework of all you that i
like
he goes a lion will sit and they'll wait
and they observe the the surroundings
they wait to see their prey
appear like what do i want to eat and
they they won't just run around
aimlessly
you know fake hunting they wait till
there's actually prey
then they sprint and they sprint until
they catch their prey and they hunt it
down
then they eat and enjoy they you know
they enjoy the fruits of their labor
and then they go back to resting and
waiting again and um
that's not how most people work what
most people do is like a cow they just
stand stand out there in the field
with their neck down and they graze on
grass all day
eight hours a day just slowly chomping
up the grass and they don't really make
much progress
and so if you're an ambitious and a
creative person you're in a creative
field like
probably most people listening to this
are uh just say to yourself i literally
say this to myself like work like a lion
i'm gonna work like a lion today
what that means is identify the one
thing i'm gonna kill today
sprint hunt it down kill it enjoy it and
then rest all right
so on the podcast you and sam parr sit
and basically just come up with idea
after idea after idea
uh i've listened to many episodes uh
some with people that
uh we have visual friends that have come
on and some with just you guys
ideating what are some of your favorite
ideas you guys have come up with
sure so i shortlisted a few um i'll just
hop around i'll just go through them so
so
we'll do it we'll do it fine i'll go
quick and you give me your hot take
reaction
uh to each one of these you can say
that's a dumb ass idea or you could be
like
i think there might be something there
um okay so the first one
is uh is hooked for romance novels so
okay so i'll tell you the quick
background
uh hooked is a is a company that is like
if you ever read goosebumps back in the
day like when you were a kid i read them
um it's basically like kind of scary
stories but they tell it through the
phone so it's like
it's in the text message format they the
app just like each line of the story is
like a text message and you just read it
so hooked is taken off it's got 50
million readers they do like 60 million
a year in revenue
uh nobody really talks about them and so
uh turns out people still like to read
they just do it in new ways
and so i think you should do this for
romance novels so
i was surprised to learn that um romance
is like one of the fastest selling
categories it's the best selling
category in
uh in books um outside of the bible
basically so like you know the
best-selling book is fifty shades of
grey
uh but there's also um you know the
twilight series um there's also
um you know danielle steele who's got a
house on billionaires row here in san
francisco that house was paid for
through romance novels
and so the average reader of romance
novels will read like five times as many
books as the average person who reads
books
as an average book reader and so there's
just this carnivorous appetite and
there's not enough supply
and so i think you should create a
lightweight mobile platform where you
subscribe 7.99 a month
and you get a know regular dose of
romance
romance short stories and um actually a
listener heard this idea on the podcast
and went and did a weekend prototype so
what he did was he
took it to an extreme he created a
newsletter instead of a book and
no app just to create a newsletter
because it's quick but he did it for
erotic stories for black women
um black mommy porn basically and told
through through you know written stories
and in two weeks he's built it up he's
doing 10k a month now on this
thing with basically no investment he
just ran a few hundred dollars of ads
on porn sites to acquire his users and
he's already doing 10k a month as
passive income now off this
you know like of a you know a piece of
this idea but
i think this idea is big and most people
who build apps are
kind of like dudes who are you know like
white dudes who don't read romance
novels and so
i like opportunities where it's not
going to be as competitive because it's
the average builder doesn't
know about this opportunity yeah and i
also wonder
uh where's he getting the content from
the person who created it he just hired
a
uh so wattpad is like a free writing
platform where people write stories so
he found a writer on wattpad i think
and was like hey i'll pay like a hundred
hundred 200 bucks a month because
writers make no money
so it's like very easy to be like i'll
give you a hundred dollars per story or
ten dollars per story whatever it is
and these are very short stories that
are just quick to consume
it's crazy and i think that the the key
piece of that whole thing is one uh
people definitely still want to read
uh two it's just a different delivery
mechanism right some of the things that
i keep thinking about is
um just like books and audio books where
else are people reading content that
just
they're gonna turn into an audio format
right like that's absolutely gonna
happen in
other verticals other than just books uh
people have tried it with articles and
all this kind of stuff but like
and that just feels like a natural
progression that'll occur exactly like
if you want to think of new ideas if you
want to get good at thinking of ideas
here's a framework that's really easy
everyone makes funny because i'm i'm
always talking about frameworks i'm like
the
i want to be like the framework don but
i don't think you could be a don if it's
something as lame as frameworks but
um it's like a two by two matrix like
two by two grid and you just write
uh is either an old problem or a new
problem and then it's either an old
solution new solution
and so like old problem people want to
read stories like romance stories
but new solution i'll deliver it to
through your phone through this new
packaging on a subscription basis
digitally
rather than traditional books um and
then there's sometimes there's new
problems like
oh i bought bitcoin and i need a place i
need a way to store it securely that's a
new problem
and i need i can use an old solution
actually i can use you know
like you know those guys who do cold
storage like in a vault it's like a bank
vault so they took an old solution and
applied it to a new space
and so that's just an easy way to look
at things old problem new problem old
solution new solution
and uh you can't the only square that's
invalid is you can't do old problem old
solution that's done
uh all the other grid all the other
squares are up for grabs
so an iteration of this that i've told
multiple people they should go build is
what i call business text
which is uh there's tons of newsletters
right now and they all summarize the
news right they basically just put links
and things like that
uh somebody should create a text-based
service uh you put your number in
and then every day at the beginning of
the day it texts you and here's all of
the headlines that you need to know
around business
right and it's got a link and you can
click through read the article if you
want if not you basically get all of
them
you can easily put some sort of
advertising in it
and you're off to the races and it
probably takes somebody half an hour
maybe an hour you know max to go collect
headlines and links and
kind of format and send the uh or the
text message it's like that's just a
super
layup one that you get tons of
distribution right out of the gate
uh and then you can do all kinds of
things to monetize with i love that one
that's great
that that's that's why you're gonna have
to be on the podcast cause you got the
jam you have the idea switch
some people don't have it you have it i
have way too many ideas
the test is like if someone wants to be
on the podcast i'm like show me the
notes app in your phone
like i'll i'll tell you in five minutes
if you'll be good on the podcast or not
absolutely what other ones do you guys
have uh okay here's okay
i did kind of a raunchy one so let me do
a very safe uh
safe for work one okay so beautiful
bibles so this this came on a podcast
uh one one of the episodes we did we
came up which was that
there are uh tons of christians out
there the bible is the best-selling book
of all time
um there's like 40 million i think met
new christians a year
and christianity religion people think
it's going out of favor but actually
there's this resurgence
so like you have you know kanye
releasing gospel albums bieber
you know when all righteous uh there's
guys like carl lentz who are like kind
of like celebrity preachers now
um that are like kind of cool and like
they can do tick-tocks and [ __ ]
um and so um so anyways really just kind
of on this upswing but the bible itself
the book that sells the most copies
still looks kind of like the dusty old
brown bible and so
there's a few people trying this but i
think there's still just plenty of
opportunity
if you're just a person with good taste
and design you should create a beautiful
bible here's why
um you're just repackaging the existing
content and you just need to package it
with either photos better cover
different form factor
something like that either something
that's you know easier to take around or
just looks good on a coffee table
it doesn't like sort of look like a
dusty old bible and
um religion is like the most you know
popular
free ip in the world so i have a whole
set of religious ideas because
where else can you get ip that is like
universally known and loved
um you know by you know hundreds of
millions of people know and love this
brand
and you don't have to pay a dollar for
the rights and like that's just an
amazing premise for any business
uh just start with that and so one of
the man one of my religious
ideas is beautiful bibles what do you
think
no no-brainer um and and i'd even go
step further as like that entire
mechanism of take uh some sort of
content that already exists and
repackage it and make it look much
better
uh you could literally go all the way
back to
uh articles newspapers religion you know
all this kind of stuff i think it's very
smart to just
tap into a massive market where you
don't have to pay for the ip
all that makes sense but the other piece
of it too is
uh you can actually go ahead and marry
the first idea the second idea right so
you can even do
a super beautiful designed you know app
where you can read it you know there's
all kinds of things that you can do off
of that and there's plenty of
i think that some of the most popular
apps in the app store are around
religion or bibles
um but but i do think that there's
another piece of this too which is
uh i'm fascinated by the idea of taking
a piece of content and then either
making it more mature or less mature and
what i mean by that
is uh you know all of these books that
are basically like
the picture book of the bible right or
the uh if you went
you looked at bible sales how many of
the bibles being sold or in the like
old uh james you know like super hard to
read
like old english type uh language versus
just like i think it's called
new american you know uh language where
it's very easy to read
uh my guess is actually that more and
more the new language
and so it's like finding any sort of
content that you can
you know basically translate into like
very simple
uh kind of concise language whether
that's you know for children or for
kind of adolescents it just seems like
it's pretty easy to do
and the demand's not going anywhere
there's some group that's trying to do
this on youtube they just took every
like
story from the bible and they're just
animating it into a youtube series
and their youtube channel is like super
popular their patreon has like tons of
you know supporters or whatever they
have like a whole animation team like a
pixar team basically
it's a again genius idea it's like
deliver in a new way
um the old content and again it's like
this can't this is ip more popular than
pokemon or anything else
and um you know you can get the rights
without permission and without
a dollar so that's really cool uh for
somebody who
doesn't have a whole lot of resources
but wants to make something big
look i think that there's an entire
industry of people just reading things
that are in written content
like literally go find you know
information that you know people find
valuable whether
books are hard because there's the ip
concerns but there's all kinds of
content that exists
you know everywhere uh and literally you
just read it
and it's not very you know intelligent
heavy in terms of what's needed for you
to be able to create the audio content
but again going back to all of these
books eventually audiobooks exploded
every piece of written content is
essentially going to at some point have
the
um have the audio version like you could
do the audio version kind of like like
so my friend started calm the
meditation app and you know calm was
like i remember early days was like
just alex and he was you know it was a
slow slog people weren't meditating and
then like
as that came more in vogue they grew but
it still wasn't taken off
and then they did their sleep stories
and sleep stories was like a game
changer because a more people wanted to
sleep than meditate
and b they had like they took an old
problem bedtime stories and did it in a
new way
they did bedtime stories for adults
driven through an app
and um so you could do the same thing so
say you did the audio version of the
bible like
maybe you actually do the same thing
they do which is they go partner with
like matthew mcconaughey and they get
him to read a story at night and it's
kind of like this cool
branded thing so how many celebrities
out there actually you know are have
faith and would love to be paid almost
in a master class style to record a high
quality
reading of a religious short story and
then you could off package those up and
offer them to people who want something
it's not just that it's audio but it's
audio done by celebrity and you're just
mashing these things together remixing
them till
you get an idea that works absolutely
one more
what's one more you got okay um
okay pick a number between three and ten
and i'll read the number i'll read that
idea off i have ten ideas on this list
i'll let you pick it up let's get lucky
three okay
um a no code pe shop okay so here's this
idea
um private equity you know known thing
you go buy up companies and you sort of
uh you either you know you have some way
to increase revenues through either
maybe a roll-up or something like that
or you're shedding costs so this is the
shedding cost version there are a ton of
apps
or software businesses out there that
are like they're doing like 700k a year
um but then they take like four
engineers to to like maintain and build
and they employ people and um so they're
not making any money and so
you can buy these apps for you know 2x
revenue
um because they have no exit nobody's
going to buy this like no no
apple's not going to buy this facebook
facebook's not trying to buy these
companies so they and they can't go
raise money because they're not like
in hyper growth mode so they're kind of
in no man's land so you can go you can
acquire these companies
and you just need a no code back end
basically where you're able to take
everything that they're doing with their
developers and you're going to turn it
into a no code
platform that can be managed and
maintained without having to write code
and so you lower your
your operational costs and you'll turn
these things that are like breakeven on
700k a year
to like profiting 400k a year and i
think that
any individual could do this and you can
create a whole shop that ex
expertise is doing this yeah i think
that you're going to continuously see
this i've got a friend who
um he's from south america and uh
he went in partnered with a private
equity shop
uh and they bought a very specific type
of business i i won't kind of reveal
their strategy but
a very specific type of business uh and
then the whole idea was
uh we're going to use technology to
replace much of the human labor
and then on top of that uh my buddy it
really understands how to use the
platforms to grow and kind of
operational efficiency and
uh worked at some large tech companies
and you just start to implement all of
those lessons learned and tactics
and next thing you know the business not
only can you
you know kind of make it more profitable
by saving costs but also you can double
or triple the the top line revenue
simply by like using the internet right
i mean like super
super easy stuff but uh i think that
more and more of these
kind of private equity type companies uh
or shops or
are waking up to this idea of you know
you don't have to initially go buy the
technology enabled company it may be
better to buy the one that has no clue
about technology and then just
quickly get them on board into the
technology world and create a bunch of
value
yeah that's that's exactly right all
right i took uh
a bunch of questions from online uh on
twitter beforehand
uh i'm gonna just run through these and
you fire off answers
uh adam singer asked to talk through
mobile
end versus mobile first and how you
think about that
yeah okay so what he's asking is you
know your company should you be thinking
we are
you know mobile and company meaning it's
mobile and web mobile and tv or whatever
or your mobile first company like when
facebook went all in on mobile um
and you know it's i think there's
context to this like not every business
necessarily makes sense this way but
like the world has gone mobile first
so you need a damn good reason to not be
mobile first
um you know if you're netflix and you're
like look people truly enjoy to watch
more a higher percentage of this on tv
than on mobile
um like mobile sizeable for them it
might be like 20 30
of their overall watch time but um still
majorities tv so like they should be tv
first
but if you're a social media app you
should definitely not be tv first you
should be mobile first right so
i think the context depends here but
like in most cases
and is a wuss word and is i can't make a
decision
so i'm gonna say both because then i'm
not pissing anybody off
and in reality i'm probably gonna fail
because i don't have the ability to do
both at a world-class level
so be really worried when you whenever
your strategy is this and that
instead of this not that i would always
bet on an entrepreneur who's saying it's
this not that even if they're wrong
because they'll
find out that they're wrong and they'll
be able to pivot when it's this and that
they'll never know if they're wrong
because
everything will just be half-baked
execution and so you never know was the
problem the execution or the strategy
it's hard to tell
literally my number one lesson from
working at facebook was this exact
framework that you're talking about
which was
uh you have to have a strategy and then
you have to have perfect execution of
the test for the strategy
for that exact reason right if it
doesn't work you never want to be
questioning well was it the right
strategy we just implemented it
incorrectly because right exactly
you're lost yeah there's no there's no
point in running the test then right
were you were you ever there when they
did a lockdown when they're like i don't
know which years you were there but like
when it was like
existential threat nobody leaves we're
we're going to figure this out we're
going to shift the whole company in this
direction
so not necessarily for that so i worked
there in 2014 2015.
um there was plenty of people who you
know kind of had the stories of that uh
when i was there we went from
i don't know i think i was like maybe
right around
4 000 3 800 employees something like
that uh
to when i left uh i think we had crossed
over 12 000
so like you know hyper growth
everything's going crazy
um but the thing that a lot of people
don't remember about facebook is that
most of the executives have been there
for a very very long period of time
right and so on the growth side
uh you know you've got hobby uh naomi
alex schultz like like these people who
have been there just for so long
and i think part of what was so
fascinating was
uh they had the muscle memory of doing
that
and where it would show up is there
wasn't necessarily like company-wide
lockdowns but they would do like war
rooms for product launches
right so kind of everyone go in here for
two weeks or you know that type of stuff
um and then uh the other thing that a
lot of people don't remember
is uh when they were doing those
lockdowns a lot of times they would
literally
stop development of everything at the
company and say
like we're going to fix the data issues
that we have so going forward over the
next
30 years like it's built on a good
foundation right or there's this
existential threat like we're going to
address that today
we don't care if we don't make progress
on anything else and it goes back to
your idea of like it's not just
startup entrepreneurs that need to focus
like if you want to be really really
good you've always got to understand
like what's the most important thing and
like how focused are we on that thing
versus distracted by everything else
totally all right uh
biggest lessons learned from monkey
inferno from marvin
uh so monkey inferno was the idea lab so
i talked a little bit about that of you
know
some of the the things that don't work
great um
i'll i'll share with you my my
philosophy around this so
the biggest lesson learned was don't be
a dabbler okay so what's a dabbler
um so here's the here's the story on
this so
um let's say you decide to go and um
and you go to the gym and you see your
gym has a racquetball court and you're
like oh let me try this out
that looks fun let me see what they're
doing so you go inside and you start
playing racquetball
and you're like holy [ __ ] this is fun
i'm smashing this ball against the wall
this is great next day you go and you
buy a bunch of gear you got your shorts
your headband your goggles whatever
you're like i love racquetball now so
you start playing racquetball for a
couple weeks
um and then you know a couple weeks go
by and you you know the initial fun of
smashing the ball around is sort of worn
off
and you actually started playing with
somebody who has been playing for a
while
and um they're just mopping you up you
know they're just putting the ball in
places you can't hit
and you're getting frustrated because
it's not you're not getting the level of
progress
or victory that you really want uh as
fast as you want it
and so you know average person's like
you know what uh [ __ ] racquetball what
am i doing in this box anyways
uh this is hot uh you know this is a
stupid stupid game
i'm gonna go play a different game i'm
gonna go play tennis and so they go they
go outside and start playing tennis
same sort of curve happens uh initially
starts out fun
you're doing all right you feel a sense
of progress but then over time you start
to
um you know you hit plateaus and you
stop getting better
at the same rate you were getting better
before and when you really want to
compete you realize like
oh [ __ ] like i still have a long way to
go and this this is not
going as fun as it's not as fun as it
was the first few days
and um so most people you know they quit
they say tennis what is this
you know i'm out here in the sun all day
this is this is dumb i'm i'm done with
this
and then they go and they're like i'm
gonna play golf and then you know day
one of golf they're like
[ __ ] uh you know golf doesn't even give
you that initial uh hit and so
you know the there's three that's the
story of a dabbler and this happens in
business all the time
where you start a project and you
initially have hopes and dreams
and it starts off going great and you're
excited but then as you hit plateaus or
resistance which is like what it takes
to get to success
um you give up and you switch or you
change your strategy or you just change
everything and you're not changing
because
that's actually what it takes to get
better you're changing because you're
impatient or you're frustrated
and so this was really easy to do in an
ideal lab because it's like
dude we got a ton of ideas it's natural
to just quit one and do another
focus your attention a little more the
next day on the other projects and so
it was really hard to do that and
there's really three types of people
there's a
dabbler who that's the pattern they go
down there's what i'll call the stressor
achiever this is where most people fall
most successful people fall here where
they're gonna fight through they will
persevere but they're stressed the whole
goddamn time every time they hit the
plateau they're angry they're frustrated
but they
they they don't quit but their their
journey is painful
and then there's a master and this is
what i've learned from monkey inferno in
my time at the idea lab was how to
become a master
a master is you are doing something you
would get excited
about the early days and you hit your
plateau but you don't you're not
surprised you're not angry you say
you treat it like an old friend you're
like ah like i thought i'd be seeing you
soon hello plateau
um you you know what are you here to
teach me where do i need to grow
to get better what area of my business
is weak that i need to get stronger
um what area of my body do i need to
change to get better um and so now
a master treats the plateau like an old
friend uh greets it
goes through it overcomes it and enjoys
the whole journey along the way and so
it's kind of a more philosophical
personal lesson but that's what i really
learned from the idea lab was
um don't be a dabbler also don't be a
stress or achiever
learn to be a master in in your
adventures and then you'll enjoy the
adventure and you'll
you'll have the endurance to continue
australia what's going on in the startup
scene there
i have no idea i was there like 10 years
ago back then it was like
every smart person i met was on their
way out um like the brain drain was real
and then there was like two companies
that were successful like atlassian
and you know now canva and everybody
always points to those is like no look
see we could do it here and like
of course you can do it there but there
was a real brain drain
at the time maybe it's changed but in
australia the startup scene was
more it was like five to seven years
behind it was the same way the tv
you know when i was there they would
show like the tv station would hype up
like
oh coming up this week house this new
show
uh house md and like house came out in
the states like seven eight years ago
and they were like no house is starting
here now and that's how i felt about the
startup
kind of uh being on the edge of things i
didn't feel like they were on the edge
and like no knock i love australia you
know i'd live there again in a heartbeat
but
you know in terms of the startup scene
it wasn't it wasn't the forefront
makes sense uh remote workspaces being
everyone's going to remote work in some
form or fashion but then
people basically going into a space
while they're working remote
uh and so you gotta watch people in the
same space they just work for different
companies remotely
what do you think of remote work do you
like it
well it's a little bit different yeah on
the investing side
obviously it's a little bit easier to do
that and i've been doing it
pretty much um for uh for four or five
years now
uh and so like you know works all the
kinks out it's fine
like is this your desk where you work
right now uh right now during quarantine
yeah but
but at one point we had an office right
then we didn't have an office
um and the way that i kind of look at it
is
uh it's one of these things where like i
actually don't think it's a company
specific thing i think it's an
individual specific thing so some people
like really don't
mind it at all they actually enjoy it
they want the freedom they you know they
want kind of all these things and other
people like i
absolutely hate working remotely like i
want to go do
you know go into an office i want to be
around people i want to like you know
sit at a conference room table like all
that kind of stuff and so
to me it's like less about like is the
company going to be successful or not or
can they be successful like again yes
of course they can be right but it's
just like who are the people i guess
yeah that makes sense i think two things
i think people are missing the big story
about this remote stuff
uh so what most people are thinking
about at least people i see kind of on
twitter and whatnot is
like oh how is my job going to work am i
going to be remote am i going to
go into these little co-working pods are
we going to is our office going to open
back up
and they think like that's the extent of
the change that's happening but what's
actually happening is actually
in some ways much more scary for that
person which is um
i like i live in silicon valley right uh
people here are divas
uh they're like you know making a ton of
money
and unsatisfied the whole time and like
expenses are really high and all this
stuff
and what's gonna happen is when you're
remote you don't have to pay silicon
valley prices for talent anymore
so it's not gonna be your the problem
you're gonna have isn't
do i prefer working out of my kitchen or
do i wanna come in three days a week or
two days a week or five days a week to
the office it's gonna be
holy [ __ ] they just found somebody in
canada that's gonna work for a third of
my price
and so most people are gonna you know
when the talent pool opens up to global
because
the default work system is remote either
remote only or remote friendly then
people who are you know you really have
to be a 10xer to get paid like a 10xer
and most people think they're a 10xer
because they're getting paid like it
today but that's just because they
happen to be
you know an engineer designer pm that
lives in you know the bay area or new
york
and that's why you're getting paid these
like you know high wages
but if i can if if you're sitting on
zoom and so is some guy in pittsburgh or
czechoslovakia um yeah sorry you're not
going to be making you know half a
million bucks a year anymore
because i don't have to pay that anymore
i'm getting the same output or better um
for somebody you know a faceless you
know output person
just think about it like they're just
going to measure output per zoom
endpoint
and um you know that's going to you know
they're going to pay 80 grand for it or
100
for it so i think companies are the ones
who win big in the end with this
and not so much the individual um
employee
well it's companies and then it's also
people who are potential employees but
don't currently work at the company
right so if you exactly anywhere
internationally for sure a huge win um
and then even
here in the united states if you're in
the midwest and in certain areas right
now all of a sudden you've got much more
opportunity and you probably actually
get paid
a premium on what you would get paid
locally uh which is still a
significant decrease in cost for the
company that was exactly
it's a win-win right company gets at
half the price and i get double my local
wage
so they're happy and so there's that
phrase like talent is universal but
opportunity is not
or something like that um that's what's
hap that's what's gonna happen the
talent that is already universally
distributed
um is now gonna receive a larger share
of opportunity to earn and prove
themselves
than is happening today same thing's
gonna happen on the funding side where
cool if i'm doing all my funding over
zoom anyways and i don't just find bay
area companies i'm gonna fund companies
everywhere
so more people get opportunity do you
think that there ends up being these
like
pods or uh remote workspaces
probably but i don't think it's that big
of a thing
so like um maybe i'm just skewed because
i like just being on my own i'm in fact
i just consider myself like a
solopreneur now i don't want to i don't
want any employees i just want to build
my own business and run it with just me
and maybe one sidekick
you know who i talk to online um
but yeah i think people will have
co-working spaces because not
everybody's house is like kind of suited
for it and
companies will need to make concessions
and say cool you can go get this space
kind of you know we have we have spaces
in every city center that you can go
work at
and it's co-working like wework or regis
or whatever
um but i don't think it's like what the
quest i saw the question on twitter and
who's like
are groups of kind of friends from
different companies gonna like form
their own little co-office it's like
yeah well like
in the sitcom friends that will happen
where like you know they meet at the
perk every day at 3 p.m
and like you know they live in new york
in these like
that's not real like that's a show
that's a tv show and that's not real and
so you know
just think logically most people are not
gonna like set up this like very perfect
scenario where my best friends from
different companies get together and we
pile up in a co-working space
uh i don't think so so the other thing
that i think is definitely gonna happen
is uh people are gonna start building
homes with two
offices right so like in suburbia
somewhere it's gonna be like hey
you know three bedroom three bath two
office right right
and and they're not gonna just be like
um you know when i was growing up
you'd go to like a friend's house and
they would basically call like a home
office but it's more of like a den
so kind of like you know glass little
doors or whatever and
uh you're just like wait a second like
that's not going to be what this is i'm
talking about a full-on
office like maybe hooked up with some
sort of audio video capabilities
right and actually serve uh maybe even
be soundproof to some degree like you
you can
start to see and it's gonna be promoted
that way
yes i would add to that also i think
multi-family real estate is gonna look
very different so
uh you know today where you have these
lobbies where people play shuffleboard
and there's like a you know whatever
like a movie room or some amenity
like they're gonna just build co-working
spaces into every multi
multi-condo um apartment rental place
because
you're gonna have all these people
they're gonna be in small apartments
that two people trying to
work from home and so a good
differentiator will be to take one or
two floors of your building
and just build out we work inside and um
i know some people some places already
do this but that will become very much
the norm just like the way you're
talking about
the office thing like i'm selling my
condo right now in sf we took our second
bedroom and we staged it as an office
not as a bedroom
and like that would have been crazy you
know three years ago but now it's like
made sense people want a big spacious
office with a good door and good light
more than they wanted a bedroom you want
to know my wildest idea when it comes to
the remote work and housing
hit me so uh malls absolutely getting
decimated
uh i think that somebody should go and
you have to have a lot of capital you
have to be super ambitious and you know
kind of do all the right things but
uh if you think of how the mall is
basically set up is
uh at the co at the ends and kind of in
the middle there's always the department
stores
right so you go in you buy mall with
huge acreage whatever
you turn the department stores into
essentially just apartments
right and then all of the
interconnectedness
of the mall which used to be retail
stores you basically build like a little
village
and so you take like the quote-unquote
new york experience or like the san
francisco experience
and you pack it into like a mall
environment and then you use the
outsides you can either
have some parking or you can actually
build like walking paths and all kinds
of crazy stuff
and what you're doing is you're almost
giving like the urban type experience or
like a college dorm type experience
uh but i think that in the right city
done correctly would be
like incredibly attractive to people who
all want to work
remotely and also then you get kind of
this bounce between work life and
outdoor experience indoor experience all
that kind of stuff
right yeah totally and if somebody
resonates with that now's the time
because now
you'll get the you'll get a 70 million
dollar
um property you know for for 22 million
bucks right now
if you if you go try to buy up these
malls that are dying and all their
stores are dying and
all that it's either that or or they
become you know amazon distribution
warehouse it's like
it's gonna be one of the two like it's
gonna be an endpoint for e-commerce or
it's gonna be co-working with
froyo shops in between absolutely
uh what are the pros and cons of my
first million success so you guys
obviously have i think
uh your two plus million downloads in
the first year um
what is kind of the pros and cons of
that success
uh well pros is easy uh it's fun to just
shoot the [ __ ]
and then you get like a bunch of people
telling you how great you are like
that's never bad
um so so that's cool and you know it's a
good platform to have
the cons would be um
[Music]
it's very tempting to think you're smart
when other people think you're smart and
my whole life i i think i actually kind
of got smart because i thought i was
dumb and i was always trying to learn
and so when you're uh when you're on a
podcast
you're basically kind of giving answers
you're giving like information
and i want to be the you know dumbest
guy in the room
um i want to be somebody who um
is like learning more than i'm teaching
right so
um so that's my mindset so i would say
the only con
is um the only con would be falling for
falling for your own [ __ ] you know
don't don't start to believe your own
[ __ ] so like
if i start to think i'm smart and people
should look to me for information or
advice like like they do
then i've lost and i've stopped growing
at that point
that's a fantastic answer what's the one
product that doesn't exist that you
would hand over your credit card
immediately
for that's a great question um
okay uh here's one right now that's kind
of top of mind
um so my wife started the e-commerce
thing during the last couple months as
like a side thing and it kind of took
off
um she basically heard people on the
podcast talking about stuff and was like
i could do that
um and so it actually worked and so i
haven't talked too much about it i
haven't really told anybody what's
happening but
one of the problems we have is like cool
it's outgrown
like our whole house of like inventory
like our whole house is filled with
inventory and then
the next ship that's coming in it's even
bigger and so what most people do is
they go to a 3pl
which is like a third-party logistics
company basically you send them your
inventory
they fulfill it and they charge you for
the storage they charge you for the
picking it out when an order comes in
and packing it and shipping it um
and they have like kind of crappy
service because they're trying to do
this for a whole bunch of companies they
don't really care like you care we care
about our customers
they don't they don't care it's not
their customer and so um
what would be better is like i would pay
today for a we work
for warehouses and so i saw this guy jay
tweet this out and it struck a chord
with me because
i would say his last name but it's like
a crazy indian last name that i don't
know how to say
um and so what what you would want is
i would rather hire my own people to go
do the pickpack and ship
but i don't want to lease out a
warehouse and buy the forklifts and buy
the
racks and like you know set this whole
thing up and like no i would rather just
say give me
3000 square feet that's what i need
right now or 10 000 square feet or
whatever it is and i'll expand to 20 000
square feet if i want to
but like i want to do my own fulfillment
um
like i don't mind having my own people
there so it's like our space we can
control it we could control
quality accuracy and costs um and so i
would hand over
my credit card today if there was
somebody in the bay area that said
um we are we are turnkey we work for
um for warehouses what type of
e-commerce is she doing
oh bro e-commerce you can never tell
what you're doing there's 10 000 drop
shippers sitting out there ready to
knock you off in a second i i
when people i have this tweet which is
like before i do something i tell the
whole world about it
once something starts to work i don't
tell a soul about it and so this falls
into that category i'll share all my
half-baked ideas i'm not doing
but if i'm doing something that is
working you you don't even know i it
exists
that is a fantastic way to look at it
uh all right last question i have for
you from the audience before we
go to wrap up for rapid fire is what are
your post
twitch plans uh i don't know it's a good
question
so i set this goal for myself that i
want to
um i want to teach one percent of
humanity um so like
i i would love to basically take the top
one percent of most hungry ambitious
people
and um and help them you know tap into
more of their potential in some way so
like
the reason i say this is uh everything
in society is set up for the average
person right you have to like there's so
many people
so we set up our school system our work
system our life philosophies for the
average person
and most people follow most people so
like
um which is crazy because most people
hate their job most people are fats most
people
most marriages end in divorce so like
why the hell would you ever follow what
most people do that's crazy to me so
um you know for the top one percent of
people who are creative and ambitious
and want to really make something of
their life
i want to create sort of the alternative
school system for them
that might just be podcasts and books
and stuff you know
places where places where you can go
self-learn i might go buy a university
campus and start my own
let's start the next stanford but it's
going to be something in the education
space and it's
going to be something for the top one
percent of talented people
and i want to reverse the brain drain
they're all going and wasting their time
it goes back to project selection and
kind of
following the herd i don't think you
should follow the herd and i don't think
you should pick the wrong projects i
think you should apply your talents in a
way that
like works for you and you'll get the
most out of your talents
um so i want to help that so after
twitch i'll probably just start on that
and that'll be like
my last project i don't want to like
build something to sell it i want to
build something that like
you couldn't buy off me and it's the
idea that uh those people would
eventually like go and create companies
or they could go do anything
yeah go do anything so like you know the
same philosophies that helped me build
businesses
would help somebody become an investor
it would help somebody become a musician
and be like hey
cool if i'm a musician like a big part
of this is standing out getting my stuff
into customers hands building a
community
um you know you know maximizing my
revenue opportunities
um so like doesn't matter whether you
want to kind of go in the creative
fields like music film
um you know that side of things or in
the business side but those would kind
of be the two main areas
um not really for somebody who's like
you know if you want to become a doctor
go to med school like that's probably
the best way
um but if you want to be some kind of
creator you know creating either content
creating uh creating businesses um this
would be a creator school
and before i wrap up i asked everyone
the same two questions
first being what is the most important
book you've ever read
um i'll give you two the first most
important book i've ever read was the
game
which is a book about uh picking up
chicks basically
um great book entertaining read this guy
becomes a pickup artist
it's more just entertainment than
anything else but um
it helped me because uh i was an 18 year
old kid in college and i wanted to
have a girlfriend and i didn't know how
to do it i was um when you don't know
how to do something you
i should just speak from the eye when i
didn't know how to do something i would
kind of like just either again follow
the herd or like
just act in weird ways out of kind of
insecurity but once i got confidence
that hey
this if i just do this this will work
and i'm in this is in line with my
values like
um i was just at ease i was at peace and
i had much better results
but it really teaches you about human
psychology so the same things that
that book teaches you about how to
approach you know a group of girls in a
club
is very much how i do cold emails for
you know outreach to customers and
you know how i would pitch an investor
how i would get an investor to want to
invest in my business and get that
attraction and get them
excited uh that's the same way i would
you know
the same thing i would use to build
attraction with an investor and get an
investor excited want to take action
would be the same thing that this guy's
saying this is how you pick up chicks at
the club
and so i i really like that book i
thought it taught me a lot about the way
human psychology works
and then the second one is this book
called story worthy that nobody really
talks about
it's probably the best book i've read
the last two years um this guy matthew
dix uh he's a storyteller
he um there's this thing called the moth
storytelling competition you might know
it in new york i had never heard of it
before but it's like a
you know talent show or whatever it's
like a kind of a local uh open
open um open mic for storytellers so
this guy's like the 20-time
champion of moth or whatever he's won a
whole bunch of these um
he's just a third grade teacher i think
in in connecticut and that's like his
day job and his
like his night job is he teaches people
how to tell great stories and this book
is awesome
it's such a good book for for learning
how to tell stories and
most of what we do is telling stories
like if you're still listening like an
hour to this podcast probably because
you're entertained by something i said
if i didn't get you it's because i
didn't tell a good enough story
at the beginning and um it's one of
those universal skills that i think
people should learn
and story worthy is an awesome book that
i never heard about until my friend
trevor told me about it and
now i it's the most gif it's the book i
gift the most i sent it in the mail
today to two
of the other execs at twitch um to be
like hey
this book is amazing it'll change your
life i've never heard of it i'm
definitely gonna have to read that now
uh i got one more question for you and
then we're gonna end you get asked me
one so start thinking but uh the last
question
is more fun aliens believer or
non-believer
that's a good question um no i'm a
non-believer
i do think i think the sort of this is a
simulation is more likely than
um than anything else and if this is a
simulation you wouldn't really need to
build aliens or maybe you would and some
simulations are not
um or or maybe the aliens are the
simulators
maybe they're this yeah you know
anything that's kind of foreign a
foreign
you know intelligent body would appear
to be an alien to us
um so yeah i'm not i don't believe in
aliens the way that like you know kind
of area
what is area 51 or whatever like e.t i
don't believe in that alien i don't
believe in ghosts
um but i do think that there's a there's
a decent shot that this is
this whole thing's not real where you
know you know when you get in a plane
and you start to fly up and then your
house starts to look like a little ant
colony and the roads start to
you know like cars start to look like
ants and houses start to look like the
colony and like
you start to realize like oh [ __ ] we
might just be in a petri dish somewhere
um yeah like i believe that a little bit
more i also had this one really
delusional thing when i was little
um that i got paranoid when i was like
in fifth grade
that i was like wait what if um i was
like what if i
you know what if i'm not like mentally
all there i was like what if i'm special
needs
and then my parents uh convince me like
all these things that i believe to be
like normal society are not like school
well that's just like a daycare where
they put
they put me uh and i was like what if
like you know
i'm drinking orange juice and what if
this is not what people what real people
actually drink what if this is just what
i drink because i'm a part of this like
and i got really worried about it and uh
then by sixth grade i was like i think
i'm okay
look when you're a kid you don't know
man you ever go to like uh
i had somebody come on the podcast this
is actually uh wild uh
so i i grew up in north carolina uh and
this kid caleb presley who works at a
barcelona sports comes on
uh he grew up in asheville north
carolina so people that grew up in
raleigh north carolina i think asheville
is like the boondocks right
and vice versa and uh he said that i
think he was 18 years old the first time
he ever heard of
evolution theory right right and he was
just like look man at every single
school i went to
you know in freaking nashville north
carolina like that wasn't a thing that
they covered
right there is this like whole idea of
like like that sounds crazy
right you know once you kind of
understand the internet and all stuff
but it's like look it's just an exposure
thing
right so you know how many years i was
taught like the freaking
uh photosynthesis cycle like why do i
need to know that why was that taught to
me seven times in my life like
that's crazy it's crazy everything that
gets taught is crazy like
everything that's taught that you
memorize essentially
and actually you're just you just you
just look that up whenever you need it
like
memorization is is bogus uh learning
about plant cells rather than like
nutrition for humans
that's crazy that we do things this way
so i'm not surprised he didn't learn
about evolution i didn't learn about
nutrition in school and that seems like
a really
important thing for everybody to learn
so one of my favorite videos on the
internet
is uh there's a mom who has her phone
and she peeks around the corner her
son's sitting at the dinner table but
he's like
you know six or seven right and he's
kind of like too small to sit
at the chair so he's literally propped
up like standing on it kind of leaning
over the table and there's an alexa
and he's got a piece of paper and he's
holding his pencil like a you know
six-year-old does
and he goes alexa two plus three you
know or whatever he says
and alexa says it back and all you hear
the mom is boy
she's about to you know get just get
them and i'm like look actually that
kid's gonna be super successful yeah
right he's got it down uh all right what
one question do you have for me to uh to
finish this up
um okay i didn't prepare for this but i
actually have a great question for you
all right i i am the master of questions
so i i i
i'm not surprised i have a great
question all right so um
you are you i didn't i never heard of
you until
like i don't know 18 months ago two
years ago something like that whenever
kind of bitcoin started going and then
this guy on my feed and he was branded
pomp and i was like that's a cool little
personal brand to have
and you like seem to be all in on
bitcoin and like crypto and like
i kind of i was like okay so like you
know who's this person is this like
some hedge fund guy is this like and i i
still actually don't even know your full
story but like you worked at facebook
and you seemed kind of like
you seem like you came out of nowhere
and you seem like you created this
pop guy um like to what extent like
okay first am i wrong what was this like
were you always
kind of uh a notable
person doing notable things it seemed
like you went from
a kind of normal successful smart person
to like
a standout and you it seemed like you
did it off this bitcoin wave and it
seemed like you almost consciously
branded yourself
as pomp the bitcoin kind of champion and
cheerleader
on twitter uh was that conscious is my
is my perception of
this accurate i'm just curious so uh
there's a whole bunch in there uh
the key pieces were um i have this
general belief that like if somebody
can be successful at one thing they can
be successful at many things
right and it's kind of the repetition
successes
to some degree now again look there's
also elements that like
you win the ovarian lottery like you
know you have extra resources like all
that kind of stuff
that helps but uh i do think that
there's like this confidence game
there's also just uh if you can tell
stories right if you are good at
communicating with people like
you can replicate it over and over again
so um
i was in the army uh deployed overseas
uh when i came back like
just that one experience alone you kind
of just have this different like i was
very different when i came back because
you just kind of like
are forced to grow up um built and sold
to
like pretty small technology companies
uh but again like
learning muscle memory when i got to
facebook that's when i think i realized
like
oh wait like i may actually like be good
at some of this growth and tech stuff
and all that
um eventually got hired at snapchat as
the head of growth uh for a short period
of time
and then like went and started investing
full-time and i only went and started
investing full-time because like i
didn't have an idea of like what i
wanted to do
like in terms of there was no company to
build yet like i just was like there's
nothing worth it so let me just go help
other people pretty much
um and in 2017 at the beginning of 17
uh the only thing i keep thinking about
was like uh when i was at facebook i ran
the grow team from facebook pages
and so i helped all of these different
brands and individuals all stuff build
massive audiences right it's like
i met the [ __ ] jerry guys like all these
guys and and not necessarily that i did
the work but just like i understood how
the system
you were front row at least yeah yeah so
i could just explain to them like hey
here's how the algorithm works here's
the things that you should do here's the
things you shouldn't do like you know
here's how you increase your reach or
decrease your reach like all that type
of stuff
and what i had realized is like i had
sat and watched so many people do this
with that information i was like why
hadn't i
never done it for myself and this is
like before all this like now like
everyone's talking about creators and
audiences like all that kind of stuff
um and so i looked at the platforms and
i was like okay which is the one that i
think you could basically do this
the fastest on uh and that was twitter
um
like because because retweeting just the
virality
yeah and it was the one that had the
least amount of algorithmic
disruption meaning that like facebook
was very obvious like they were taking
away reach like all that kind of stuff
and twitter seemed to still like
have a pretty long way to go before they
got to that point um
and also it was like easier to create
content for right
if you're gonna sit like right up
facebook right
and so uh i just tried everything and
anything in the book like whatever i
could
and that year um i went from
i don't know like low single digit
thousands to a hundred thousand
or like 110 000 followers so okay like
here we go
so so you said you tried a bunch of
things uh what's an example of something
you tried that you don't do anymore or
or that you were trying at that time so
literally like literally
um i come from like that growth mindset
so it was like what are all the things
that you could possibly do that could
like drive
people to your profile to hit the follow
button so uh
follow one follow like reply to tweets
tweet you know 50 times a day
um retweet your own tweet because
there's different time zones that people
may be logging in like
i mean like everything in the book that
you could possibly think of
um and three or four years ago some of
the stuff worked that doesn't work now
some of this stuff didn't work but
actually would work now
like it all was just testing how did you
decide your angle
uh so it's to me that the angle was
twofold that i recognized you for one
was a
memorable kind of name that like you
know it's easy easy to kind of uh
hook on to and the other is you were
talking about a topic that was like
super relevant and everybody wanted more
info from
um did you consciously decide that or
that just kind of happens no
so this is the craziest part of the
whole thing is um
for whatever reason i grew up with four
younger brothers there's five of us like
we're all just like pretty authentic
like i'd like to think down to earth
like you can go grab a beer with us and
i don't care if you're
a billionaire or you're a nobody like
you know we're just us
right um and uh
i think that what i started to do
was just talk about the things i was
interested in and i was trying and i was
talking about all kinds of stuff
everything from
um technology to startups we had
invested in
to bitcoin to you know whatever and
naturally the thing
that most people i think do on twitter
is they fight what's actually working
like like they want to talk
about bitcoin they want to talk about
what they eat they want to talk lakers
and yeah
all this stuff and it becomes like not
obvious like what is this account for
uh and i knew from facebook like oh no
no like
super focus is actually the best thing
and so in the beginning it was just like
a bitcoin tweet went viral then another
bitcoins we went viral like two weeks
later and i was like wait a second like
okay let me try another bitcoin like
okay viral and it was just like the
algorithm basically like
it was just obviously double and triple
down on this uh the name
people have been calling me pomp since i
was you know in middle school
right it was just like these confluence
of events that in hindsight like oh yeah
i'm this like master genius
there was no master plan like it was
just i just knew that like building the
twitter audience would be
effective and i think the advantage that
i've had is uh
because we've invested in so many
companies and and i've just seen like
what works and what doesn't work
uh i've been able to kind of like pretty
intelligently i think
navigate like okay once you build a
twitter audience like now you've got
platform risk like
okay can you port that audience to an
email okay now you got that like
how do you get another platform okay
let's go to audio right and you just
kind of like
do that um and then also you're like
okay now we're in 2020 and like
everyone's talking about like oh if you
have audience you can like build
businesses
and i'm like yeah of course like
no-brainer like i've got an audience
so yeah so basically there was no master
plan from how to go you know from uh
where i was to today but
it's one of these things where like when
you find yourself in a certain position
like
i think generally if you've just got
sound decision making like you can make
the best of it and so
yeah now what's the best version of how
this plays out over the next five years
roughly like
what's what's the best outcome of where
this whole thing goes for you now where
does the pop train go
uh short answer i don't know is all of
these um
like influencers celebrity you know
people with audience whatever
historically they've basically said uh
give me money and i'll advertise for
your business
or they say you know smart people will
say give me money and give me equity now
but i think actually it's gonna flip and
what you're gonna see is the people with
audience are just gonna say i'm just
gonna build my own company
right so like the joe rogan example like
joe should have gone to trigger girls
and said hey
i'm not advertising trigger girls
anymore let's create an entity we're
going to call it joe rogan grill i think
that's where the world's going
and more and more people will figure
that out pomp's instant pot
got it it's an instant pot with your
face on it
it plays your content while you while
you cook your food it's excellent
nah i think i stay out of the kitchen i
don't think the kitchen items are going
to be my thing
awesome sean listen thank you so much
for doing this uh where can we send
people to uh to find you on the internet
or uh or find out more about some stuff
you're working on
yeah just uh follow me on twitter uh
that's where i put out most of my my
stuff
uh so it's just twitter slash sean vp so
it's s-h-a-a-n-v-p
so sean vp and then uh subscribe to my
first million podcast if you like kind
of
what we were doing here just shooting
the [ __ ] talk about different business
ideas this
basically what we do twice a week and uh
it's got a good thing going so so if you
like that go
go subscribe to my first million i'm a
big fan
you don't even know this but uh i've
listened to a lot of the episodes so
definitely people go subscribe
uh no brainer for that yeah and i think
we got you scheduled on next week maybe
something like that
yeah we're gonna do it great um all
right man thank you so much we'll do
this again in the future
cool peace out